The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Hi.
Our lesson, today, hopefully
will serve two purposes.
On the one hand, we will give
a nice application of the
chain rule.
Now that we've had two units
devoted to working with the
chain rule, I thought you might
enjoy seeing how it's
used in places which aren't
quite that obvious--
places that we wouldn't expect
to be used, at least.
And secondly, I would like to
pick as my application one
which comes up in many, many
different contexts.
And without further ado, the
topic I want to cover today is
called "Integrals Involving
Parameters".
Now, that sounds like
a big mouthful.
Let me motivate that for you,
first of all, physically, and
then in term of a couple
of geometric examples.
You all know from past
experience my great ability
with physical applications, so
I won't even try to find
anything profound here.
Let me just take a pseudo
example, pointing out what
type of situation we're trying
to deal with and leaving it to
your own backgrounds to see
places where the same
principle could have been
applied, but hopefully in a
more practical, meaningful
way for you.
Imagine for example, that we
have a platform that we're
looking along in the
x direction.
And we've punched holes in this
platform, say, and liquid
is trickling through these
various holes.
The holes are all on a
horizontal line this way.
What we're going to do is
we're going to focus our
attention on a particular
particle of the liquid, and
we're going to watch
it as it falls.
And what we would like to do is
find how far that particle
fell, say, during the first
second of its flight.
Obviously, from a calculus point
of view, the first thing
we have to do is know what the
velocity function is, because
ultimately, we would like to
integrate the velocity.
Now, notice that we would expect
the velocity to be
depending on time.
If this were a freely falling
situation, we'd expect the
usual gravitational
type situation.
Or whatever the situation
happened to be, we would
expect on the one hand that
the velocity does
depend on of time.
On the other hand, because of
how the streams are flowing--
in other words, we don't know
what's happening above here
that's causing the water to
shoot out-- we don't know what
the initial velocity is coming
out of each of these holes in
the sense that a different
opening may give rise to a
different velocity of
stream coming out.
All I'm trying to bring out
here is that as we try to
focus our attention on a
particular opening, we find
that the velocity of the
particle that will follow it
during that first second is a
function both of its position
x-- in other words, x sub 0 in
this case, because we're
focusing at x equals x0
and the time t as t
goes from 0 to 1.
And we then simply integrate
along the
vertical direction here.
We find y as a function of x0
from 0 to 1-- v(x0, t) dt.
Once we're through integrating,
you see, notice
that the integration is
with respect to t.
So when we're through
integrating, this being a
definite integral, t
no longer appears.
We have a function of x0 alone,
saying nothing more
than the distance that the
particle falls during the
first second is a function of
the position of the opening
along the line here.
Now, at any rate, the practical
application is not
so much writing down this
equation as the
inverse is the case.
Namely, in many practical
applications, we are given
this particular integral.
And for some reason or other,
want to determine
what v itself is.
In other words, we often want
to find the derivative given
the integral.
All right.
Let's just let it go at that
for the time being.
The important point is that I
want you to see an example of
an integral.
Let me just write this here
in more abstract form.
It appears to be a definite
integral, a to b.
The function inside the
integrand is apparently a
function of two variables,
x and y--
say, in this case x0 and t.
One of the variables is a
variable of integration--
in this case, y--
and the other variable is being
treated as a constant.
And that's where the word
parameter comes in. x is a
parameter, meaning a variable
constant, in the sense that,
for this particular problem, x
is chosen to be in some domain
and remains fixed.
In other words, this is some
function of x when we're all
through here.
All right?
As a geometric example, imagine
the following situation.
We have a surface w = f(x,y).
We take the plane x = x0 and
intersect this surface with
that particular plane.
We get a curve, you see.
Now, we look at that curve
corresponding to two points, p
and q, where p and q are
determined by the y
values a and b.
In other words, p corresponds
to y = a.
q corresponds to y = b.
And now, a very natural question
that might come up is
that we would like to find the
area of this particular plane
region, in other words,
the area of this slice
between p and q.
Now, you know, the first thing
I hope that you'll notice is
that because this shape of the
surface can be in many
different ways, the particular
cross section that we get does
depend on the choice of x0.
Different slices--
different planes x = x0 will
give us different curves of
intersection.
The point is that once we have
the curve intersection x is
being treated as
the parameter.
This particular curve is
given by what equation?
f is a function of x0 and y.
See, x = x0 for every
point on this curve.
And so the area of the region R
is the integral from a to b,
f(x0, y) dy.
And the question that very often
comes up is, how do you
find the derivative of A sub R
with respect to x0, noticing,
you see, that A sub R is a
function of x0 alone, the y
dropping out between the limits
a and b when we perform
the operation of integration.
A third place that this type
of situation occurs is in
solving certain differential
equations.
For example, suppose we're given
a particular curve and
that that curve determines a
region R between the lines x =
a and x = b.
Suppose all we know about
the curve is its
slope at any point.
We know that its slope at any
point is given by dy/dx and
some function of x and y which
we don't necessarily have to
go into right now.
And let's suppose, for the
sake of argument, that we
solve this first order
differential equation.
What we'll find, if we're
lucky, is that y is some
function of x and an
arbitrary constant.
Remember, once you have one
solution to a differential
equation, you have an infinite
family in terms of a one
parameter solution to a
differential equation.
In other words, in finding the
area of the region R in this
case, there are many curves that
satisfy this particular
differential equation.
Until we know what specific
points are being referred to
over here, the best we know
for sure is what?
That these endpoints are a and
b, that the integrand is
f(x,c), and we're integrating
that with respect
to x from a to b.
I freudianly put a c in here,
because I think what I was
trying to emphasize for you is
that when you look at this
thing, observe that
this integral is a
function of c alone.
Namely, when you integrate this
thing, you integrate it
with respect to x.
The x drops out.
All you have left here is a c.
A sub R, then, is
a function of c.
And in many cases, what we would
like to do is see how
fast the area changes
as a function of c.
In other words, how do we change
the area as a function
of changing the arbitrary
constant c?
And I have enough exercises in
the assignment to give you
concrete drill on this.
All I'm trying to give you here
is an overview of the
entire topic.
And the reason I want to give
you this overview is that it's
hinted at in the textbook,
but this topic
is not covered there.
In fact, the reason that I had
you read that particular
section of the textbook before
the lecture this time-- you
notice that usually we start
with the lecture.
This time I had you read the
textbook first, because the
way the textbook covered this
topic is essentially nothing
more than the way we
tackled a different
problem last semester.
And I want you to see that the
problem done in the Thomas
text is not a new problem--
it's one that we've
done before--
but that with the tools that
we now have available, we
could've tackled a more
significant problem.
And that's the one I'm electing
to do here and what I
want to show you the key
steps on, because
they're not in the text.
But I will leave the
reinforcement for the exercise.
At any rate, hopefully now, when
you see an integral of
this type, it will not
bother you too much.
In other words don't worry about
how do you integrate a
function of two independent
variables?
When you see something like
this, it means that there is
some implicitly implied
domain for x.
In other words, we have
some function of x.
Let's say the domain of g might
very well be, say, all
x's between two values,
say c and d.
But who cares about
that right now?
The important point is that
g is defined on a certain
set of values x.
And what it says is to compute
the output of the g machine.
For the given x, you fix that
x and integrate f(x,y) dy
between a and b.
Notice, you see, during the
integration, x is being
treated as a constant, so that
for all intents and purposes,
this is an ordinary integral.
But because x isn't a bona fide
constant, meaning what?
It's a constant only in the
sense that once chosen, it
remains fixed for this
particular integration.
Different values of
x will give me
different integrals here.
And consequently a very natural
question that comes up
is how does my function g--
which depends on x--
how does that vary
as x varies?
In other words, the key question
is simply this.
First of all, given g defined
this way, one, does g prime
even exist?
Does dg/dx exist?
And two, if it does
exist, what is it?
In other words, the question
that we're raising is if we
can find g prime of x, how do
we do it in terms of looking
at the right hand side?
And let me not try to guess
the answer here.
The answer does turn out to be,
in this particular case,
one that you might
have guessed.
But I prefer to show you
that we don't have to
guess, point one.
Point two, if you do
guess, you won't
always be that lucky.
That's my finale for
today's lecture.
But let me see if I
can survive to get
to the finale first.
Let me see how we'll tackle
a problem like this.
First of all, to see if g prime
exists at some value x0,
what we have to do is--
way back to the very beginning
of Part 1--
the same old definition for
an ordinary derivative.
We have to compute the limit of
g of x sub 0 plus h minus
g(x sub 0) over h, taking the
limit as h approaches 0.
Notice what the g
machine does...
What the g machine does is it
feeds x into the integrand
here and integrates this with
respect to y from a to b.
So if the input of my g machine
is x0 plus h, that
means that the x is replaced
by x0 plus h here. g of x0
plus h is simply integral
from a to b f of x0
plus h comma y dy.
Similarly, g(x0) is integral
from a to b f(x0, y) dy.
I now want to form
this difference.
And noticing--
again, this is all calculus
of a single variable--
that the difference of two
definite integrals is the
definite integral of the
difference, I can conclude
that g(x0 + h) minus g(x0)
is simply this single
integral over here.
Now, my next step in determining
g prime of x0 is I
must divide this by h.
Notice, by the way, that h is
an arbitrary increment, but
once chosen, remains fixed.
Notice that h is a constant
as far as this
integration is concerned.
Consequently, to divide by h, it
is permissible to bring the
h inside the integrand.
In other words, technically
speaking, the h should be
here, but since h is a constant
with respect to y,
the integral can have
the h brought in.
Why do I want to bring
the h in here?
Let me again telegraph what
I'm leading up to.
Obviously, when I'm going to
compute g prime, my next step
is to take the limit of this
as h approaches 0.
With h in here, I look at this
and what I hope is that by
this amount of time at least the
following minimum amount
of material has rubbed off on
you in a second nature way--
that if I look at this
expression in brackets as h
approaches 0, this is precisely
the definition of
what we mean by the partial of
f(x, y) with respect to x
evaluated at (x0, y).
See, this is what?
The change in f-- see,
y is held constant.
We're taking this over to change
from x0 to x0 plus h
and dividing by h.
This is a partial of f
with respect to x.
That's why I want to
bring the h inside.
So now, I say, OK,
g prime of x0, by
definition, is this limit.
I now want to take the limit
of this expression.
And by the way, notice what I'd
love to do now is to jump
right in here and say, aha, this
is just the partial of f
with respect to x evaluated
at (x0, y0).
But the thing I would
like you to notice--
and again, going back to Part
1 of course, one of the big
things that we talked about
under the heading of uniform
convergence.
There is a very dangerous
thing in general to
interchange the order of
limit and integration.
This says what?
First perform the integration,
and then take the limit.
What we would like to be able to
do is first take the limit
and then integrate the result.
Now, we did see that, provided
the integrand was continuous,
these operations were
permissible.
But we'll talk about that
a little later.
For the time being, let's simply
summarize by saying if
the limit operation and the
integration operation can be
interchanged, then
the derivative--
see, this thing here is what?
This is my g(x).
The derivative of g(x) with
respect to x has the very
delightful form that,
essentially, all I have to do
is take the derivative
operation, come inside the
integrand, and replace the
derivative with respect to x
by the partial derivative
with respect to x.
In other words, the derivative
of the integral from a to b,
f(x, y) dy is the integral from
a to b, the partial of f
with respect to x dy--
provided, of course, that the
limit and the integration are
interchangeable.
In particular, this will be true
if f and f sub x exist
and are continuous and see,
straighten out the range and
the domain and what have
you once and for all.
Notice that y is allowed to
exist between a and b.
We've said that x is going
to exist on some domain
between c and d.
Notice that saying that y is
between a and b and x is
between c and d geometrically
says that f is
defined on a rectangle.
See?
OK.
And then what we're saying is,
under these conditions, to
integrate an integral with a
parameter, with respect to
that parameter, all we have to
do is come inside the integral
sign and differentiate--
take the partial derivative--
with respect to what is being
used as the parameter.
In this case, it's x, which
is the parameter.
Now, the only danger with this
particular thing-- and by the
way, notice, not only is there
a danger here that I'm going
to mention.
The danger is this looks so
easy, you may be saying, why
did he do it the hard way?
Why didn't he just tell
us this was the right
way of doing it?
And the point is it just happens
to be one of those
coincidences where the rigorous
way yields a logical
answer which is consistent
with what is probably our
intuitive guess.
But it's not always going
to happen that way.
And the example that I have in
mind now goes back to what we
were talking about the beginning
of the lecture.
Namely, I wanted to give
you an application
of the chain rule.
And here's where that
application comes in.
I now call this--
I don't know what to call it.
So let's just call it variable
limits of integration.
Same problem as before--
it's going to cause the chain
rule to come in now.
The only difference
is going to be--
and that's just a forewarning.
You don't have to know
that right now.
I'm going to have the same
problem as before.
What did I have before?
I had that g(x) was integral
f(x, y) dy between the two
constants a and b.
Now, I'm going to let my
constants of integration also
depend on the parameter.
See, all the constants of
integration have to be our
constants as far as
y is concerned.
What I'm saying is what makes
this problem differ from the
previous one is suppose that
it happens that instead of
being given a nice rectangle to
play around with, I'm given
a couple of curves like
this in the xy plane.
See, this would be a of x.
This would be y equals b(x).
See, what I'm saying now is
that not only does the
integrand depend on what value
of x I pick, but the limits of
integration as I'm finding a
cross-sectional area of a
surface, you see.
The limits of the integral
themselves depend on the
choice of x--
constant, as far as y is
concerned, but depend on x.
You see, now, what happens is
that my parameter appears in
the limits as well as just
in the integrand.
And now, you see, also what
this means is if I try the
previous approach of computing
g(x plus delta x), et cetera,
I'm in trouble, because the
only way I can combine two
integrals and put them under the
same integral sign is if
they're between the same
limits of integration.
Notice here, for example, that
if I replace x by x plus delta
x, I not only change the
integrand, but notice that the
limits become what?
a of x plus delta x, b(x plus
delta x)-- and those in
general, unless a and b happen
to be constants,
will vary with x.
In fact, let's look
at it this way.
This is the problem we should
have started with in the sense
that constant limits of
integration are a
special case of this.
At any rate, what I wanted
to show you was that this
particular problem can be
handled very nicely in terms
of the chain rule.
Namely, what we do here is we
observe that, first of all, y
is not really a variable here.
It's integrated out.
So what we think of is let's
think of x as being some
variable u.
Let's think of b(x) as being
some variable v. Let's write
down the function of
three independent
variables u, v, and x.
OK.
What will that function be?
Let u, v, and x be arbitrary,
independent variables.
Look at the integral from
u to v f(x, y) dy.
This is obviously dependent
upon u.
It's dependent upon v. And
it's dependent upon x.
The place that the chain rule
comes in is that in our
particular problem, u and v
cannot be arbitrary, but
rather u must be that particular
function a(x), and
v must be the particular
function b(x).
Consequently g(x)
is simply what?
It's h(u, v, x), where u
is a(x) and v is b(x).
Consequently, to find g prime of
x, what we want is h prime
of x and to find h prime
as a function of x.
See the chain rule here?
u can be expressed
in terms of x.
v can be expressed
Obviously, x is already
expressed in terms of x.
So this is really implicitly
a function of x alone.
So by the chain rule, what I'd
like to be able to do is to
combine these three pieces
of information to
find h prime of x.
And remember how the
chain rule works.
Now, I'm not going to
beat that to death.
We've just had two
units on that.
Let's just say it
rather quickly.
g prime of x is the partial of
h with respect to u times u
prime of x plus the partial of h
with respectively to v times
v prime of x times the partial
of h with respect to x times x
prime of x, which, of
course, is just 1.
In other words, writing this
thing out, g prime of x is
simply this.
What is the partial of
h with respect to u?
Let's come back here for a
second and remember what h is.
h is this integral.
I want to take the partial of
that with respect to u.
That means I have to
investigate this.
Now, here's the interesting
point.
Whereas u, v, and x are
independent variables, what
does it mean when you say you're
taking the partial with
respect to u?
It means that you're treating
v and x as constants.
Now, if v and x are being
treated as constants, what I
have is simply what?
I'm taking a derivative with
respect to a variable where
the only place the variable
appears is as the lower limit
of the integrand.
In other words, I claim that
that's nothing more
than minus f(x, u).
Then I go inside
the integrand.
In other words, I differentiate
the integral.
That leaves me just
the integrand--
and replace the variable
by the variable of
integration u here.
And because it's the
lower limit, I put
in the minus sign.
Now, why did I go through
that very fast?
That's why I had you read
this assignment first.
Notice that the assignment in
the textbook does not touch
what I'm talking about, but
rather seems to review that
topic that we covered
under Part 1--
that if you wanted to take an
ordinary derivative with
respect to u, integral from u
to a, g(y) dy, the answer
would just be minus g(u).
And that's exactly what
I did in here.
I treated v and x as
constants here.
In other words, the only
variable in here was u.
That will be emphasized again
in the exercises.
In a similar way, the partial
of h with respect to v means
this thing.
Notice now that u is being
treated as a constant.
x is being treated
as a constant.
To differentiate this, my
variable appears only as an
upper limit on the integrand.
That means I come inside the
integral sign, replace the
integral by just the function
itself, replacing what?
Replacing y--
that's the only variables
of integration--
by the upper limit v. In other
words, this is f(x, v).
All right?
And finally, the partial of h
with respect to x is this
integral here.
Notice now that u and v are
being treated as constants.
With u and v being treated as
constants, that's the special
case that we started out lecture
with, namely, to
differentiate with respect to a
parameter when the parameter
appears only as part
of the integrand.
So how do we do that?
We come inside.
This is the interval from u to
v, the partial of f with
respect to x dy.
Putting the whole
thing together--
recalling, among other things,
that du/dx, since u is a(x),
is just a prime of x and that
dv/dx is b prime of x-- what
this says--
and again, I want to see the
beauty of the chain rule here,
because at least to my way of
thinking, I don't see anything
at all intuitive about the
result I'm going to show you.
And that is as soon as you make
the limits of integration
variable, to differentiate
an integral involving a
parameter--
you see again, what's the
parameter here? x.
We integrate it with
respect to y.
This is a constant as far
as y is concerned.
See, intuitively, you might say,
gee, all you've got to do
is take the derivative sign,
bring it inside, and this
should be the answer.
See, it's the same
as we did before.
The point is-- and this is where
many serious mistakes
are made in problems involving
integrals of this type--
is that the reason that our
intuitive way happened to be
right in the simpler case was
that these were constants with
respect to x.
Now, they're variables.
Well, it turns out, if you just
wrote this thing down,
you would be wrong.
What is the correction factor?
Again, come back to here.
The correction factor is this
here, which we've just started
to compute.
Again, just saying it--
if you wrote this term down to
get the correct answer, you
would have to tack on what?
b prime of x times f(x, b(x)).
That means what?
You think of a y as
being over here.
For the particular value of
x, you replace y by b(x).
In other words, you look at f(x,
y), and every place you
see a y, replace it by b(x).
And then subtract that
from that a prime of
x times f(x, a(x)).
Now again, I suspect that, for
many of you, it's the first
time that you've seen something
like this, because I
say it's a topic which I believe
was a natural one to
occur in the textbook, but
for some reason it
doesn't appear there.
Because of the importance of
the concept, the number of
times it appears in physical
applications, the number of
times that one has to
differentiate with respect to
an integral--
I don't know the physical
applications well enough to
lecture on them, but it does
occur in probability theory,
among other places, it appears
in any subject involving
integral equations
and the like--
that I wanted to give you the
experience of seeing what the
concept means, to have
you hear me say it.
And then I will spend the
exercises trying to drive home
the computational know how so
that you will be able to do
these things at least in a
mechanical way, independently
of whether the theory made that
much sense because of the
lack of physical example
motivation other than what I
did at the beginning.
At any rate, keep in mind,
though, that in terms of our
present topic, where we're
talking about the chain rule,
this is a certainly noble
application to show an
important place in the physical
world where knowledge
of the chain rule plays
a very important role.
And with that, I might just as
well conclude today's lecture.
And until next time, good bye.
Funding for the publication of
this video was provided by the
Gabriella and Paul Rosenbaum
Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.